Uh, Donald told me a funny story recently about Chappelle on the road with
Chappelle. He said,
he said they got a hotel wrong because not all the hotels got a
hotel to take a. When you're Dave Chappelle, you got to take a on the road,
just get a hotel room and go take a in there. Yeah.
You don't want to in the lobby. And I get it. I mean, if I was Dave, yeah.
Somebody sees you bothers you. Why you shouldn't. So I just like,
they pulled over for a second. He took a. Then he took a,
took a shower and came out like, yeah, bro. If Donna was here,
he would go off on me. So he just, it just in case it comes in the future.
I took a booboo on the tour bus and go, boop,
boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop.
You're not Muslim. Talk about it. Yeah. So it was a whole thing.
It became a whole thing.
It's definitely a no-no on tour buses and it was a situation. Definitely.
Everybody was, it was so funny though. The whole, I mean,
you can't on the floor boss, babe. Let's say Donald Rollins was juicing.
This guy in Syracuse, New York was taking out a Jew.
He went and bought a juicer and was juicing all the leftover veggies from the
green room that he had in the fridge. And he was making these Jas,
putting them in jars. It's like, yeah, let's do this goose,
chugging them decent right there. That made you want to. Ooh,
two, three o'clock in the morning.
Cause we left direct to a Rochester after that and things had to happen.
You know, what am I going to do?
I'm going to ask Dave Chappelle's tour bus to stop. So I can go for me.
I just in my head. Cause you're going in the holiday Inn lobby.
You're not getting your own rooms. I mean, yeah, I'm shut up.
I'm going to be dancing somewhere. I was just like, Oh, it's fine.
He's going to empty the tank. And that's what they do.
And everything will be fine. Just forget about it. And uh,
that's not what happened. I never thought about that.
It was a feign according to where you,
but that's the way you could really quantify it. Like when you're doing good,
like he's at a level where he gets a hotel room. Yeah. I mean,
you could do that now you can price line a room for like 50,
$60 and still comfortable in there. Yeah, you could. Yeah. You could do it.
Yeah. You could. He's not like pullover four seasons only. Right.
You know what I mean? It wasn't really that expensive,
but you princess though Prince has gone like yeah,
I got to take a and they're like, there's a holiday and he's going, yeah,
my in the holiday Inn, Dave Chappelle, chits and holiday, bring me,
it. Highest five-star hotel you can find.
And then he probably gets the suite in the five-star hotel. in there. Yeah.
That was walks out. That was a fun tour though. That was a fun.
That was a fun leg of that tour. It was. So it was the first time.